now if you're without valentine this  valentine's day heartbroken anonymous  may offer the support you need it's a  virtual group created by a former  producer of the bachelor it offers a  non-judgmental space for members to talk  about relationships friendships even  loved ones they've lost each has an  uninterrupted platform to express  whatever is on their mind to those who  can relate  once you get over that hump of sharing  and being vulnerable  and then you feel that connection with  other people then you feel less alone  and it's not as scary  you can head to our website  eightnewsnow.com to find a link to the  group